[موسيقى
] الجناح مستوحى بالفعل من
بانكوك ،
إنه مصطلح تاجالوج قديم
للشعاب المرجانية تم تقسيم كل جزء من الجناح
إلى مناطق
مثل التدفق من قصة إلى أخرى ،
نبدأ بجزء من الارتباك في
الغابة المقلوبة
هذا  العمل الفني هو إعداد الفلبيني
والزائر لقصة جديدة
عن الفلبيني ثم ينتقلون إلى
جزء رحلة المطر الذي هو في الواقع
قصة حركة الاستيلاء
من هناك ننتقل إلى عمل فني
حول قارب
وهو قارب صوفي للغاية  يتحدث
عن حركة البحر مرة أخرى
للفلبينيين
من هناك ، ننتقل إلى اللولب ،
وهو منحوت جميل مصنوع من
المعدن
ويتضمن في الواقع أسماء حوالي 200
فلبيني يعملون ويعيشون هنا في
الإمارات العربية المتحدة
[موسيقى]
تم تأليف الموسيقى  من قبل
فناننا الوطني للموسيقى الدكتور رامون
سانتوس
[موسيقى]
، إنه يتكون من عدة
نغمات وموضوعات مختلفة ،
والموسيقى أصلها بالكامل  nal
وقد تم تأليفه خصيصًا
للجناح ،
فقد تأسس على
التاريخ واه على الموسيقى الأصلية
ولكن في نفس الوقت قام برفعها إلى
مستوى معين
فكري تمامًا وحديث تمامًا ،
فقد اعتمد على آلات الرياح
والإيقاع بشكل جيد لإنشاء أصوات
تقريبية
الطبيعة
[موسيقى
] صوت
البحر وصوت الرياح والهواء بالإضافة إلى
العناصر الطبيعية مثل الطيور
[الموسيقى
] التجربة التي نحاول بيعها
هنا في المعرض
هي تجربة تحكي قصة
شخص لديه  تاريخ قديم
يعود إلى ما قبل 4000 سنة
[موسيقى]